[Music]
you told me the story of the war when
the ground shook in the sky burn of the
ones that survived
who will woke to a different world where
the powerful right but that's not the
way it has to be when I found you you're
very human brain was miraculously it's
the loneliest feeling not to know who
you are in time you'll remember
[Music]
Elita is doing here it's horse world on
here did that'll be willing to do what
it takes
[Music]
Mika's she's the last of a kind
she contains technology that have been
lost for 300 years
let me show you something
[Music]
this body I feel a connection to it I
can't explain you know more about me
than you're saying of Leda some things
have better left forgotten and I'll find
out for myself
she's threatening the natural order
thing I need you to destroy her Leda
they will come for you I'll have to face
them head-on
tonight is not a gated
[Music]
[Music]
I miss her you go in there you race you
win you come back right here maybe where
all of these pads remember if you wreck
this body I can't fix it yes I know
tonight is not a game
[Applause]
a girl called deleted
[Applause]
Elena it's a setup you got to get out of
there they're gonna kill you
which ones all of them go easy on me
guys sure kid
no worries
[Applause]
[Music]
Elita battling Jun this body it has the
power I need I feel a connection to it I
can't explain this could be Who I am
you've been given a chance to start over
with a clean slate how many of us get
that I did an enemy warship respond to
me because I knew that ship I've been on
others like it haven't I haven't I oh
whatever you were it's not who you are
now hi memoria are not
the woman in my memory called me 99 what
you saw was a flash of your previous
life who was I in time you'll remember
the action the emotion the grand world
it was all there I saw it as this great
female empowerment story an incredible
artist named Kushiro created bolita
battle angel 30 years ago cuz she rose
creation is something that inspires
dreams
Elita battle angel is about a girl who
is plopped into the world not knowing
who she is solid and she goes on a
journey of self-discovery and discovers
that she's not an insignificant girl at
all
she is someone quite extraordinary
dancing little fleas
it's all about this if you can make the
audience believe that that character is
real a tight close-up and frankly what
are the only people that I trusted to be
able to do that I think we've been able
to create a seamless blend of
live-action and synthetic action in one
single frame
she's just realer than real if you asked
me about the timing of making Alita it's
not the technology who is finding Rosa
Salazar Rosa cells are fantastic I'm a
warrior aren't I
I loved her and I felt like her she was
my person to look up to it's amazing
seeing Rosa's spirit her light come
through the Alita character when you see
something like this it's like something
that looks so different than anything
else we need a movie like this right now
and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what they want you to think
at least I run rip that flea
watch your toys
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the underworld from here
there are worlds about world's above the
world's swear I used to live and it's
where you're going to die
dancing little flea
[Music]
Elita is dropped into this world and
through her eyes you are experiencing
everything for the first time I knew
when I did avatar with WeDo but a leader
would not only be possible that as a
character she would be spectacular
hi when we were making avatar I would
tell people we don't need to be photo
real because you can't tell me what real
is on Pandora we only needed to be
photographic or a leader where on earth
a leader needs to be photo real so that
she can stand right next to Christoph
Waltz and look together of one in the
frame Aleta is probably the most
ambitious digital character that we have
created I'm so good there's no better
way of doing that than capturing a
performance from a real human
performance capture gives you the body
and the weight and the realism of the
expressions the way the performance
capture process worked is we had a
number of cameras placed around the set
that would record markers or the actors
physical body the system would interpret
that marker and put it into
three-dimensional space and create a
skeleton to go inside a CG model to
drive that CG models performance this
body it has the power I need I feel a
connection to it I can't explain this
could be Who I am it takes some getting
used to you're wearing a helmet with
Mike pack battery microphone a titanium
boom a recorder you're zipped into the
suit and you have gloves it's all the
difference in the world for us being
able to work on set and actually capture
an actor in a proper environment because
you just get a better performance from
the actors
performance capture tends to lend a lot
of credibility because you get all of
the weight you get the physics and also
needs them to be taken to the next level
when you talk about something like
representation of manga we really wanted
to be able to take this augmented
animation hybrid and layer against the
forms capture to attain sort of the best
version of old walls what changes it
from being motion capture to performance
capture is that simultaneously with
capturing the body's performance we are
capturing the facial performance it's
all about this if you can make the
audience believe that that character is
real in a tight close-up
Rosa would wear to high-definition
cameras as a Hedrick that would
photograph her face Rena would interpret
those images on a frame-by-frame almost
on a poor by poor level to drive the
facial performance of the character of
Aleta every pull every indent every scar
every crease things I wish they didn't
put in are there it's like looking at me
because every little nuance of my face
is there touch up again and I will kill
Hughes amazing seeing roses spirit her
light come through the Alita character
my hope is that when people are watching
this they sort of forget that she's a CG
character
I'm amore your honor you know you've
always known I think we've been able to
create a seamless blend of live-action
and synthetic action in one single frame
that's pretty intense
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human you were the most human
person I have ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
Alida you have to be responsible there's
someone very special hey kid not just a
teenage girl hey what's your problem you
can't remember what do you mean doc
found you in the scrap yard so you must
be from up there and I'm just an
insignificant girl that's what they want
you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am
I do yeah the most advanced weapon ever
but that's just a shell it's not bad or
good
that part's up to you
I do not stand by
in the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
is a heart
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
we made the biggest mistake of your life
and what's that
under estimating Who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
you